Bueno, la Ley 21.719 y el futuro de los datos escolares.
Hoy vamos a desgranar un cambio de paradigma absoluto y urgentísimo
en la forma en que las instituciones educativas chilenas
tienen que gestionar la información digital de ahora en adelante.
Con la entrada en escena de la nueva Ley de Protección de Datos Personales,
que básicamente busca alinear a Chile con los estrictos estándares europeos,
todo el sector educativo se enfrenta a una transformación, digamos, radical.
Y es que procesar esas montañas gigantescas de información cada día
ya no es un simple trámite administrativo de archivar papeles, no.
Ahora exige una acción inmediata, milimetrada y, sobre todo, sin ningún margen de error.
Para arrancar este análisis hay que plantear la gran pregunta.
¿Están seguros los datos de los estudiantes?
Pensemos por un momento en un colegio o una universidad cualquiera hoy en día.
A efectos prácticos, son auténticas minas de oro de información digital
y, además, tremendamente vulnerable.
No estamos hablando de guardar cuatro nombres y un par de notas.
Hablamos de historiales médicos completos, perfiles psicológicos,
dinámicas familiares enteras e incluso datos biométricos.
Si todos estos sistemas no están blindados a cal y canto,
el peligro no es solo un problema reputacional para el centro,
sino que afecta de lleno a las personas más vulnerables y protegidas por nuestra sociedad,
los menores de edad.
20.000 UTM. ¡Madre mía!
Detengámonos un momento en esta cifra para entender bien la magnitud de lo que está en juego.
Hablamos de la multa máxima estipulada para las infracciones gravísimas bajo el nuevo marco legal.
Para ponerlo en perspectiva,
la multa máxima estipulada para las infracciones gravísimas bajo el nuevo marco legal
es de 1.300 millones de pesos chilenos.
Una auténtica barbaridad.
Con la nueva Agencia de Protección de Datos Personales asumiendo plenas facultades
para aplicar estos castigos,
queda clarísimo que hacer la vista gorda ha dejado de ser un riesgo teórico.
Ahora es una amenaza financiera capaz de paralizar y hundir a cualquier sostenedor o centro educativo.
Y esto nos lleva directamente a entender el cambio de paradigma,
la diferencia entre la realidad antes de 2024 y lo que nos espera en diciembre de 2026.
En diciembre de 2024, correcto, pero estableció un periodo de gracia,
una adecuación de 24 meses.
Así que en diciembre de 2026, ¡pum!, la ley entra en vigencia al 100%.
Ahora bien, que nadie se engañe, este margen de tiempo no son unas vacaciones,
es una cuenta trasimplacable para auditar datos,
reescribir formularios de arriba a abajo, cambiar sistemas informáticos enteros
y, sobre todo, formar al personal.
El tiempo que queda es el justo y necesario para evitar acabar en el punto de mira de los inspectores.
Comparemos un momento el estándar antiguo de la ley,
ley 19.628, con el nuevo panorama.
Históricamente, era súper común tirar del consentimiento tácito o global, ¿verdad?,
una sola firma de los padres al arrancar el año escolar,
y ale, eso parecía cubrir absolutamente todo,
desde usar una aplicación de matemáticas hasta subir fotos de la función de fin de curso a las redes sociales.
Pues bien, ese modelo ha muerto, está completamente finiquitado.
El nuevo estándar exige algo muchísimo más complejo,
un consentimiento granular, libre e informado y sumamente claro,
respaldado además por una estructura de protección que está a años luz de lo que conocíamos.
Y aquí, precisamente aquí, tocamos el corazón de esta reforma para el mundo educativo,
la famosa tutela reforzada.
Suena a concepto jurídico muy denso, pero en la práctica es fascinante.
Significa que los datos de niños, niñas y adolescentes, los NNA,
adquieren un estatus de protección drásticamente más alto que el de cualquier adulto.
Es como un súper escudo legal.
Un menor jamás puede consentir por su cuenta,
requiere una autorización verificable y robusta de sus padres,
o tutores.
Y un detalle clave, la ley prohíbe de forma absolutamente tajante
usar datos de menores para fines comerciales, publicitarios o de creación de perfiles.
Cero excepciones.
El pilar filosófico y legal de todo esto se resume a la perfección en el artículo 16 quater.
La norma lo dice textualmente.
El tratamiento de los datos personales que conciernen a los niños
sólo puede realizarse atendiendo al interés superior de estos.
Ojo con esto, porque cambia las reglas del juego.
Cualquier decisión que se tome, cualquier app tecnológica que se contrate
o cualquier dato que se guarde, tiene que justificarse única y exclusivamente
porque beneficia al alumno.
Nunca, jamás, por simple conveniencia burocrática del colegio.
El interés superior del menor pasa a ser la prueba de fuego de cualquier auditoría.
Claro, imaginemos el impacto operativo masivo que supone todo esto.
Es, literalmente, el fin del consentimiento global,
la muerta de la firma única.
Ese formulario tradicional de matrícula de una caricia,
donde se marcaba una casilla genérica aceptando todas las políticas del centro,
hoy en día es papel mojado bajo la ley 21.719.
Ahora los centros tienen que desglosar con un nivel de detalle milimétrico
para qué van a usar cada dato.
Y un matiz fundamental, si mañana un padre o tutor decide
que quiere retirar el permiso para una actividad en concreto,
tiene que poder hacerlo exactamente con la misma facilidad con la que lo dio al principio.
Es decir, nos enfrentamos a un mapa de consentimiento granular.
Pensemos en cómo se divide esto ahora.
Por un lado, la inscripción puramente académica,
que requiere su propia aceptación.
Por otro lado, si el colegio quiere publicar fotos en su Instagram o en su web,
eso requiere un segundo consentimiento totalmente independiente.
Y si van a compartir datos con plataformas educativas de terceros,
pues hace falta un tercer permiso.
Cada finalidad tiene su propia casilla, y atención a esto,
el negarse a marcar una de esas opciones adicionales jamás puede ser excusa
para dejar de prestar el servicio educativo básico.
Ahora bien, hasta aquí hablamos de datos normales.
Pero el riesgo se dispara y se multiplica de forma exponencial
cuando entramos en el terreno de los datos sensibles.
Esta es la línea roja absoluta.
Más allá de correos electrónicos o direcciones,
los colegios manejan a diario información súper íntima
que exige la protección más brutal y estricta de todas.
¿Por qué?
Porque un mal uso aquí puede provocar discriminación directa
o dejar a un menor en una situación de extrema vulnerabilidad.
Y efectivamente, un solo error manejando estos datos
es lo que te catapulta directamente a la multa de las 20.000 UTM que comentábamos antes.
Vamos a aterrizarlo con ejemplos concretos
que encontramos a diario en cualquier escuela.
Hablamos de las fichas PIE, del programa de integración escolar,
hablamos de la huella digital para el control de asistencia o el comedor,
de las evaluaciones psicológicas o de los expedientes médicos pediátricos.
Son datos sensibles de manual.
La ley nos obliga a que su tratamiento tenga un consentimiento por escrito expreso,
cifrado obligatorio de alto nivel y acceso restringidísimo.
De hecho, muchas veces va a requerir hacer previamente una evaluación de impacto.
No son papeles más en un archivador.
Son auténtico material inflamable
a nivel normativo.
Pero claro, la película no termina en los ordenadores de la secretaría del colegio.
El eslabón débil y el quebradero de cabeza de muchos administradores
son los proveedores y las famosas plataformas educativas o EdTech.
Hay una regla de oro en ciberseguridad que aplica perfectamente aquí.
La privacidad de una institución es tan fuerte como su proveedor tecnológico más débil.
Hoy dependemos de la nube, de sistemas de gestión, de apps para hablar con los padres.
Y compartir la información de los alumnos con terceros sin tener un marco legal blindado
es, lisa llanamente, una infracción gravísima.
Para no perdernos, hay que tener clarísimos dos roles jurídicos fundamentales.
Por una parte, tenemos al responsable del tratamiento, que es el colegio,
el que decide por qué y para qué se piden los datos.
Y por otra, está el encargado del tratamiento, que es la plataforma EdTech.
Ya hablemos de gigantes tecnológicos o de opciones súper consolidadas en la región
como Yumo o Colegium.
Estas plataformas procesan la información en nombre del centro educativo.
Por tanto, esos acuerdos de palabra, o el crear cuentas masivas sin un respaldo jurídico férreo,
son prácticas que hay que desterrar de inmediato.
Es justo en este punto donde entran en acción los famosos contratos de encargo de tratamiento,
o DPAs por sus siglas en inglés.
Y subrayemos esto, son totalmente obligatorios.
Es un requisito legal indiscutible tener un documento formal y firmado con cada proveedor
que vaya a rozar, aunque sea mínimamente, un solo dato de un estudiante.
Si operamos sin este contrato, tanto el colegio como el centro educativo,
como la empresa de software, se quedan completamente desnudos a nivel legal,
expuestos a sanciones millonarias e inspecciones implacables.
Y que nadie piense que esto se soluciona con un contrato de copia y pega.
Un DPA requiere cláusulas muy, muy precisas.
Tiene que especificar exactamente qué datos se procesan y para qué.
Debe fijar los límites de retención, o sea, cuando se borran los datos definitivamente
una vez que el alumno abandona el centro.
Y, atención, la parte más crítica.
Debe incorporar un protocolo estricto que exija la plataforma,
notificar cualquier hackeo o brecha de seguridad en un plazo máximo de 72 horas.
Si un proveedor no es capaz de firmar y garantizar eso,
legalmente el colegio tiene prohibido usar sus servicios.
Así de claro.
Llegados a este punto, la cuenta atrás para el cumplimiento es real.
Teniendo la vista puesta en esa entrada en vigor total de diciembre de 2026,
hay que pasar a la acción.
Adaptar toda la estructura de un centro escolar a esta nueva realidad
no se hace ni en un mes ni en dos.
Exige una planificación metódica, paso a paso.
Para garantizar que absolutamente todo el ecosistema digital esté en regla
antes de que empiecen las auditorías.
Para simplificarlo, el plan de acción tiene cuatro pasos clave.
auditar todo y crear el registro de actividades de tratamiento, el RAT,
sabiendo dónde está cada mínimo dato.
reescribir todos los procesos de matrícula
incorporando ese consentimiento granular del que hablábamos.
identificar a todos los proveedores tecnológicos
y dejar firmados esos DPAs obligatorios.
designar a un delegado de protección de datos,
el famoso DPO, que será la figura interna encargada de vigilar
que nadie se salte las normas en el día a día.
En definitiva, adaptar los colegios a la Ley 21.719
no es un mero trámite para esquivar multas millonarias.
Es una inmensa responsabilidad ética que no se puede iludir.
El paradigma ha cambiado para siempre
y la tutela reforzada de los datos de niños, niñas y adolescentes
es hoy por hoy la prioridad número uno al diseñar cualquier proceso educativo.
El reloj corre y el momento de blindar los sistemas es ahora.
Así que nos despedimos dejando esta reflexión en el aire.
¿Está realmente preparado el sector educativo
para proteger a sus ciudadanos digitales más vulnerables?